the ECB coming out with its announcement
any minute it has just broken let's go
to John Farrow in London with the latest
John Scarlett no change there was really
no decision to make on the right side of
things you're looking at a benchmark
rate of 0.05 percent you can't go much
lower than that Scarlett today was all
about the press conference that comes in
45 minutes time Mario Draghi ECB
president has got a mission he wants to
get the balance sheet up by 1 trillion
euros the big question is how does he do
that he's got a cheap funding program
called the tout row the targeted
long-term refinancing operation the
appetite from banks at the moment is not
very big for that so what does he do
well today is about a plan about buying
abs here in the eurozone big questions
how big is that plan going to be how
much risk is the ECB going to put on
their balance sheet and how much
opposition is going to come from the
Bundesbank John Farrow I'm curious the
lending facility that the ECB maintains
for its member banks negative 20 basis
points in other words you you give us
your money we're going to charge you how
are banks responding to that our banks
responding to that not clear right now
and actually if you look at the take-up
of the loans from the tout row Adam it
was very very small 80 2.6 billion euros
which tells you something there's not
much demand for credit out there
nevermind about easing crediting making
these banks lend that just isn't the
demand there if there was that take up
would have been a lot bigger Adam yeah
understandable and ECB President Mario
Draghi as you pointed out John is going
to be addressing all of us at seven or
rather at eight-thirty that's in 45
minutes 8 30 New York time what are we
going to hear from him I think we go
back to what I said about two minutes
ago it's about how big this asset-backed
security purchase plan can actually be
he's not going to come out with a size
nobody expects them to do that but
everybody expects them to talk about
eligibility there's been some talk in
the UK meter about him buying Cypriot
and Greek asset junk bonds that would
assume a lot of risk for the ECB's
balance sheet and it brings out back to
what I talked about which is the
opposition to conduct in these kind of
policies the opposition to assuming so
much risk on the ECB's balance sheet and
Adam you don't need me to tell you where
that opposition is going to come from
all right I want to bring it out and
park our guest host for the hour of
Morgan's
you're the chief US equity strategist
there when mario draghi speaks at 830am
and potentially gives details on his
asset backed securities purchases what
kind of effect would that have on the
earnings potential for of US companies
well I don't know about the Ernies in
near-term but I just I hear the stuff
and I think I like US stocks right I
look around I think I like the biggest
50 or 100 US equities I think they have
a better cash flow potential and better
growth potential than most other asset
classes i see so although you said they
might like small I like so I like small
even more I mean other words I know to
me you look at the US and you and you
tell me what you think looks better you
want to buy government bonds that yield
one percent in other countries you want
to buy there is no alternative so to me
I yeah I just think the u.s. really does
look it's not even the best sauce in a
bad block it's just a good house in
absolute terms if I'm hearing you're a
you're also talking about bar billing in
portfolio you like the largest 50 okay
fine that's a proxy for us growth but
you also like the Russell 2000 which is
about what 1,200 basis points cheaper I
just didn't think tactically it's
oversold too much too and they'll catch
up the reasons we talked about but yeah
that's kind of what I think I don't know
if it has an immediate impact on on
corporate earnings I just think it makes
me feel pretty good about the US
economic strength relative the other
parts of the world and the u.s. earnings
outlook well Jonathan Farrow tell us the
earnings outlook for European companies
especially as so many investors await
Mario Draghi and look for him to do
something more than just this modified
QE that they went there waiting for
full-blown QE well Scarlett we look at
about 12 months back when everybody was
complaining about the strength of the
euro a lot of the noise didn't just come
from the politicians it came from some
of these big exporters here in Europe
over the next couple of quarters now
we've seen the euro come down
substantially you may see that start to
feed into earning so a lot of people
talking to me a lot of equity strategist
fund managers picking out the stocks
with the international exposure to get
that translation effect from the weaker
currency what I'd say back to you
Scarlett is look at Japan dollar yen it
got very very weak yeah out corporates
in the short term look at the economy
now what's the economy doing doesn't
look good does it